(Doorbell rings)
- [Both] (mumbles)
- It's okay just-
I'll go open it.
(Doorbell rings)
- Shani, door.
- Fuck off, yeah?
(Upbeat music)
- [Jenna] Okay, so I think you owe me
like 2.50 for the movie
but you can pay me whenever you want
- Wait-wait-wait
- I'll give it to you right now. One sec.
- Okay so now you owe me 300 for the Uber,
for the mini punjab cardinal,
also 300 for the popcorn and coke
and 1,000 for that Gundi Valley wine,
- Jenna, we'll sort it out.
- [Jenna] Hey, how do
you think this looks?
- It's nice, I mean uh,
Where are you going?
- I'm going for a party.
- Mhm!
- Thanks.
- Hey, I have a date
tonight, what do you think?
What is wrong with you?
Who wears this to a date?
Are you crazy?
Do you ever want to get laid?
- [Shani] Oh hey, by the way,
My mom is coming to town.
- Oh nice. How long is she gonna stay?
- I don't know, like
two, three weeks maybe?
- Shit, my mom is gonna
be here in half an hour
- [Jenna] I have a work thing,
do you have anything
formal that I can borrow?
- Mmmyeah, I think I
should have a black shirt
that's right in front of that
- yeah?
- just check
- This one?
- Yeah
- Oh.
- Your papa's gonna put these
back in my cupboard or what?
- [Jenna] Oh, hey. If
you don't mind could you
smoke next to the window, I'm
- I'm so sorry I didn't realize, sure.
- Window.
(Snazzy Jazz music)
- [Shani] This is my boyfriend, Tamid,
Tamid, that's my roommate
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- 'X' man, press 'x'
- I know that
- Guys, today. Can we please go I'm hungry
(Peeing)
- It was like one super big piece
like greenish-yellow, you
know it's ack, disgusting.
(distant panting)
(Jazz music)